j'espère ça va être un chef-d'oeuvre
comme d'habitude il va sûrement y avoir
un dinosaure qui va sortir et qui va
tout détruire plus de cent plus de
dinosaures qui mange tout le monde des
clins d'oeil du premier retrouvez les
acteurs ça m'a vraiment génial
magalas
ça
on est on est à peu près tout casque de
caste puisque réalisateur magie la
génération qui ont vu qu'ils ont vu ce
film et mai au cinéma on était assez
âgées pourquoi aller voir au cinéma donc
cessé il ya quelque chose quand même là
c'est émotif tout va de pouvoir le faire
de relancer dans cette musique à la
division ethnique
je suis dans ce film je ne sais quoi on
est à paris
c'est la première
il
porter
vous comprenez on y va pour réparer
vitamines et minéraux
evans
la gamme et police
c'est un bel hommage le premier j'ai
bien aimé c'était j'avais attendu film
depuis 2001 donc ça valait la peine
c'était très bien très bien fait très
surprenant et on était accroché du début
la faune et s'agripper à moi c'est
vraiment génial
j'ai adoré ils vont dans la lignée du
premier plein d'action on en prend plein
les yeux la 3d parfaite juste ce qu'il
faut on rigole parfait quoi